we were talking about this business and
how this business people can sometimes
look at someone like you and think oh
it's it's easy you had many years where
you struggled and you went out for a lot
of auditions and well even drive into
Burbank it's where we taped today it's
hard for me to drive to Burbank because
this to me is the city of rejection yeah
because there's a lot of places to
audition in Burbank and so when I Drive
had drove here today I felt I felt like
I got a little a little sweaty because
you used to drive here too you know
you'd invest your day to drive out to
Burbank to audition and then the casting
director asked you to get on all fours
and eat a cracker by the way do you is
that really that really happen well he
goes do you mind taking your shoes and
shoot the socks off and by the way do
you mind getting on all fours and then
we're gonna stick this cracker your
mouth when did you find out that he
wasn't a casting director when I
realized this is a Craigslist ad that
guy's well-known and there is a there
yeah I mean how must have gone on
countless auditions where it's just well
there was a there was one audition I
went on and and then after the cracker
incident I didn't get on all fours it
neither cracker I kept my shoes and
socks on I just left but before that
there was a lot of commercial auditions
and I remember once I got called into an
audition and there was nothing but guys
over six feet tall and they were all
chiseled and I thought oh I guess they
need a fat guy in this one too and I'll
just be I'm the fat guy and I don't know
I turn to you
I don't care I just like attention yeah
it's just happy the weird response so
anyway so the casting director calls in
all ten of these good-looking guys in me
and he says so you guys are all hockey
players and you've you've won the mr.
hockey the Stanley family Cup Stanley
Cup and you're in the locker room and
you're celebrating and you know feel
free to take off your shirts and in my
mind I'm thinking nobody's gonna take
their shirts off this is ridiculous
yeah okay action all ten guys shirts off
I didn't know what to do I just sat down
like this I just took off my skates
[Laughter]
[Applause]
right the middle yeah
you